>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> So in your experience,
what would people be surprised
to learn about the Library of Congress?
>> Well-
>> I would say that it's their library.
That, that, that it's just
not Congress' library.
That it's really the nations library.
And that anyone 16 or older is welcome here.
And these are their collections.
And we've been collecting a long time
and have wonderful things for them.
>> Right and if you can't
make it to the library,
you can also contact us through
"ask a librarian".
So, the library is literally open to anyone,
anywhere, all they need to do is ask.
>> And I guess I would say,
there was this 20th century myth
that everything was in the Library of Congress.
We had everything in the world ever published.
Not quite true [laughter].
And then the 21st century version of the
myth is that everything has been digitized.
Everything in the Library of Congress.
Everything in the world is out
there, freely available on-line.
And that's not true either.
So, as we said the "ask the
librarian', but also really worthwhile
to talk to librarians where you live.
You know, to, to use your school
libraries, use your public libraries.
Often people can go to public universities
and they can help you find
all that we're finding too.
So, we all work on this together.
And I would just remind people.
This is your library and those
are all your libraries too.
So make use of us.
>> Yes.
>> I think one thing that has really
surprised me, is really what you said
in the sense that "it's everyone's library".
And I'll have a lot of people from
home say "Well how do I get in there?".
And not only can you get in there, but I keep
running into amazing librarians and staff,
who go above and beyond to
help you find information.
That as you all kind of referenced today, I
didn't even necessarily know I was looking for.
But they helped me on that path
and they put things in front of me
that I am always surprised to see.
And I've been in, I just counted up
today, a dozen of the reading rooms.
For different research purposes.
And continue to be amazed at not only what
is there, but how easy it is to access
when you take advantage of the
librarians and the reading rooms.
>> So as a science teacher.
And a high school science teacher, I
think it'd be easy to fall into a trap
that I only need to teach photosynthesis, right.
And or teach about mitosis.
And then here, I'm starting to
look at these collections that are,
I mean humanities collection, right.
What can I learn from historical texts,
where scientists maybe wrote this?
Or maybe I'm looking at historical photographs.
Or I'm looking at old newspapers.
And so, the boundaries within
science and that separate science
from history class, for instance.
They start to disappear in some ways.
So being here at the library
is really challenged me
to think a little bit beyond
the text book, right.
And think beyond some of the
standards that can be pretty narrow.
And to really exercise a creativity that got
me into teaching, I think in the first place.
And that makes me a learner
and makes me love learning.
And so being here at the library's
really allowed me to rekindle,
or just even expand, my thinking even more.
Just because the collections there.
These are documents that humans created, right.
And humans, human history very complex.
And human thinking, right.
And so, I think that's been
really exciting for me to see.
>> I bet Peter could find you a poem
about photosynthesis [laughter].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.